[Musique]
je travaille dans le domaine de la
défense depuis 20 ans je suis civile je
suis pas militaire dans ce secteur de la
défense
j'ai exercé aussi bien dans le domaine
public que dans l'entreprise où j'exerce
actuellement et aujourd'hui c'est en
tant que citoyenne surtout que je
m'adresse à vous pour beaucoup d'entre
vous beaucoup d'entre nous la défense
c'est ça ça peut être ça encore ça et ça
des images très concrète presque viril
très visuel incarner on en voit à la
télé dans les médias c'est concret mais
peut-être que la défense c'est aussi ça
ou ça
quand vous buvez un verre d'eau du
robinet quand vous travaillez derrière
votre ordinateur avec ou sans vos
collègues vous faites quelque chose qui
repose sur la défense nationale
parce qu'en réalité rien de cela ne
serait possible si les infrastructures
critiques du pays que sont entre
approvisionnement en eau ou la sécurité
de nos grands réseaux télécommunications
n'était protégée quotidiennement par les
acteurs de notre défense allons plus
loin
la défense c'est peut-être aussi ça ou
ça oui quand on lit un livre un magazine
un journal quand on invite des amis pour
une soirée on répond à un besoin bien
naturel de réalisation de soi
d'enrichissement personnel social
rappelons nous ce que disait massiot ses
besoins la de réalisation personnelle
on ne peut les accomplir que parce qu'on
a d'abord satisfait certains besoins
primaires basique parmi lesquels le
besoin d'être en sécurité
et si le plus grand des luxes c'était
d'être en sécurité sans même s'en rendre
compte
alors bien sûr il ya les attentats
charlie le bataclan nice bien d'autres
dans le monde en france et à ces moments
là oui on se rappel de l'importance
d'être en sécurité
la réalité c'est qu'entre deux attentats
ce sentiment s'estompe on oublie on
oublie qu'on a de la chance finalement
d'être bloqués dans les embouteillages
quand on rentre de vacances on oublie
que c'est une grande chance que de
s'énerver quand on fait la queue au
supermarché et que ça prend trop de
temps parce que la personne avant vous
on n'a pas pensé à peser
ses fruits et légumes on oublie qu'on
est gâtés
quand on peut gronder un de ses enfants
parce qu'il est rentré trop tard de
boîte de nuit
oui on a de la chance parce que tous ces
moments là montrent que nous sommes
globalement épargnés des tourments de la
guerre et oui et si le plus grand luxe
était d'être en sécurité sans s'en
rendre compte
pour ceux d'entre vous qui douteraient
rappelez-vous les témoignages de la
seconde guerre mondiale où certains
témoignages de conflit actuel
quand on vit sous les bombes quand la
moitié de la famille et au front ou a
été faite prisonnière
quand on a faim parce qu'on est
rationnée sur le plan alimentaire
quand on n'arrive plus à dormir la nuit
parce que toutes les 20 minutes des
sirènes d'évacuation retentissent et
bien tout change
oui le plus grand des luxes c'est d'être
en sécurité sans s'en rendre compte
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire être en
sécurité entre en sécurité contre qui
contre quoi qui est l'ennemi est ce
qu'on est en guerre à quoi ressemble la
guerre aujourd'hui
pendant des années la guerre a opposé
des états c'était simple un état attaqué
un autre état ils l'envahissait
conquérir c'est son territoire le but
c'était de s'approprier ces richesses de
le pilier ou d'imposer son référentiel
idéologique et culturelle
l'ordre international issu de la seconde
guerre mondiale repose sur la
prédominance des états on a créé
l'organisation des nations unies le
crime d'agression les conflits armés
repose sur l'idée d'un affrontement
entre états la décolonisation s'est
cristallisé autour de la revendication
de certains états à devenir indépendant
et à être reconnu en tant qu'etat
pendant très longtemps les états on
était l'alpha et l'oméga des relais
internationale mais ce monde là il a
volé en éclats la mondialisation a
changé la donne certaines entreprises
comme les gaffes à certaines
organisations non gouvernementales
certaines idéologies sont des vrais
acteurs de notre géopolitique
aujourd'hui certains ont peut-être plus
de poids que certains états la
mondialisation c'est aussi
l'augmentation colossal des flux de
marchandises et d'individus dans le
monde
facilité va des moyens de transport
beaucoup plus rapides et performants et
à moindre coût et la mondialisation
c'est aussi des flux d'information
massif et instantané
ça change tout cette mondialisation elle
est porteuse bien sûr de beaucoup
d'opportunités mais en matière de
défense
elle recèle beaucoup de vulnérabilité
donc la politique de défense elle doit
s'adapter et elle s'est adaptée la
politique de défense de la france et le
monde s'est accélérée et notre politique
de défense
à redon a suivi la même accélération
la france a produit quatre livres blancs
les livres blancs ce sont les documents
qu'ils analysent l'état du monde et qui
définissent la politique de défense et
l'outil de défense dont on a besoin
quatre documents de ce type ont été
produits au cours de notre histoire 22
ans séparent les deux premiers 14 ans
les deux suivants et les deux derniers
donc cinq ans d'écart dans un monde où
tout va plus vite il aurait été quand
même surprenant voire inquiétant que la
pensée stratégique française ne
s'adaptent pas avec la même agilité
alors ces deux livres blancs ils ont
produit une rupture de paradigme majeur
ils ont décidé d'arrêter de parler de
politique de défense mais de parler de
défense et de sécurité nationale parce
que pendant longtemps la défense c'était
le fait d'envoyer des militaires le long
ou à l'extérieur de nos frontières
dans les années 90 on parlait beaucoup
des opérations de maintien de la paix et
on avait oublié peut-être d'insister sur
le fait qu en projetant des gens à
l'extérieur
pays il contribue à la sécurité du
territoire et donc les deux derniers
livres blancs ont décidé de rapprocher
ces deux notions et de les rendre
indissociables l'une de l'autre défense
et sécurité nationale comme
consubstantielle l'une de l'autre
la lutte contre le terrorisme c'est sans
doute la plus belle illustration de ce
binôme âge entre ces deux politiques le
terrorisme a vraiment profité de la
mondialisation
pendant si longtemps on a eu du
terrorisme d'état avec des
revendications claires d'accession
d'indépendance le terrorisme aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus ça ce sont des mouvements
diverses diffus fragmenté plus ou moins
structurés formalisé certains parlent
même du b risation de la guerre face à
cela comment réagir
et bien pas seulement en agissant sur le
territoire national mais en allant à la
source du terrorisme
c'est pourquoi la france mais pas
seulement la france se mobilise sur la
bande sahélo saharienne
alors certains diront que c'est
peut-être dans une logique post
coloniale ce n'est pas le cas cinq pays
de la zone sont associés aux côtés de la
france dans l'opération barkan la lutte
antiterroriste elle se fait sur le
terrain par le démantèlement et l'action
de terrain par la projection de force et
lutter contre les foyers terroristes en
afrique c'est sécurisé le sol national
et européen
la force barkan ces deux dernières
années elle a mis à mal de 150
terroriste localement et détruit 17
tonnes d'armes
c'est pas rien alors si on projette des
forces pour sécuriser le territoire
national et européen
il est légitime de se demander ce que
l'union européenne fait l'union
européenne est au mali
il a une mission qui s'appelle yout m
mali on n'entend pas beaucoup parler
pourtant il ya plutôt de quoi être fier
23 états membres se mobilisent au mali
au moment où je vous parle
600 militaires européens au mali qui
agissent ensemble pour former l'armée
malienne et l'aider à terme à prendre
elles mêmes en charge ces enjeux de
sécurité
les européens ont formé 8000 soldats
maliens c'est à dire les deux tiers de
l'armée malienne
on n'en parle pas beaucoup sur la bande
sahélo-saharienne pardon
cette zone là elle est critique en
matière de terrorisme
mais il ya d'autres endroits où nos
forces se projette aussi dans la lutte
antiterroriste aussi pour contribuer à
notre sécurité
je pense par exemple à l'opération chat
mâle et des frappes en irak et en syrie
dans le cadre d'une résolution des
nations unies
1200 hommes et bien sûr notre protection
au quotidien passe par la force
sentinelles treize mille hommes sur le
territoire national au total ce sont
trente mille hommes et femmes qui sont
déployés opérationnellement en france ou
à l'étranger pour notre sécurité
trente mille et pourtant nous ne savons
que très peu de chose d'eux on voit
quelques reportages mais c'est très
désincarné pourquoi est ce qu'on sait si
peu de chose de sans doute parce que
depuis quelques années on considère que
la défense c'est une affaire de
professionnels
il ya 200 ans
le service national était en vigueur
puis on a décidé de le suspendre
c'est amusant parce qu'il n'ya pas si
longtemps que ça on avait tous dans
notre entourage quelqu'un qui allait
faire l'armée qui s'apprêtait à faire
son service militaire
c'était un sujet de discussion dans les
familles ça va rendre sont déroulés
d'études compliqué dans quel régime en
va-t-il c'est un peu comme si la société
reconnaissait cette espèce de tranches
de vie que les jeunes gens consacrer à
la défense de la nation
la professionnalisation elle était
évidemment nécessaire les menaces sont
extrêmement complexes pointues elles
nécessitent d'avoir des personnels
professionnels
entraînée et résilients être militaire
ça ne s'improvise pas mais nous devons
être vigilants à ce que cette
professionnalisation n'affaiblisse pas
le lien entre l'armée et la nation
c'est notre responsabilité l'idée ce
n'est pas que nous prenions les armes du
tout l'idée c'est que nous nous
intéressions davantage à l'action de ces
hommes et de ces femmes que nous
sachions en quelque sorte apprécié
l'invisible alors pour conclure j'ai un
aveu à vous faire c'est que je voulais
dit ça fait 20 ans que je travaille sur
les questions de défense mais tout cela
je l' ai compris qu il ya peu de temps
gelé en réalité compris le 11 janvier
le 11 janvier 2013
c'était le 1er jour des frappes
françaises au mali
à la fin de cette première journée de
frappes chef de bataillon damien boiteux
est mort héroïquement à mopti il était
pilote d'hélicoptère dès le premier jour
il a reçu un tir ennemi dans l'artère
fémorale l'hémorragie était énorme
elle n'a pas pu être contenue mais
damien a tenu bon et il a ramené son
hélicoptère et tout son équipage sur la
base arrière
il les a toutes sauvées
il est décédé
damien boiteux avait 41 ans il s est une
compagne et un ado de 15 ans sa maman
marie claire nous a confié que damien
voulais être pilote d'hélicoptère depuis
l'âge de 7 ans il a servi 22 ans dans
notre armée
je vous parle de damien parce que ça m'a
frappé j'en suis pas fier c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai compris ce que tout
cela voulait dire
mais au delà de damien depuis 2000 il ya
200 militaires français qui sont morts
en opération extérieure pour notre
sécurité
alors sachons apprécier l'invisible et
devenons les ambassadeurs de notre
défense nationale
merci
[Applaudissements]